hey everybody what Christmas right
around the corner we decided to give you
the gift of an early peek at our next
review enjoy and Happy Holidays who are
you I am no one
like Jake Lloyd no one I was raised to
do one thing I got nothing to fight for
whoa a black guy nothing will stand in
our way I will finish what you started
I'm not lost got Walker sequel to the
most popular nostalgic film trilogy ever
what new nitpicky things with gigs
obsess over this time
now stories
it's true all of it so he walks
destroyed the Empire
I was already reading the script for
Indiana Jones I just didn't care
the force
just like today but my midi-chlorian
count isn't high enough to have a force
critic we're home where do you spend
your nights okay so um we have been
called in to give our opinion of the new
Star Wars Force awakens review that is
coming out soon neither of us have seen
this trailer yet but we are very excited
you said that there was gonna be a
sandwich here well yeah it's a wonderful
thing you see you watch something and
then they pay you money to say what you
thought about it but you had to watch
the thing first I haven't eaten since
well then we'll go ahead get started all
right you ready you ready okay stammers
you ready you ready you ready okay here
we go oh my god it's the greatest chance
I've ever seen in my pack why are you so
excited oh my god we're not even emitted
in yet and it's beautiful when you said
trailer I thought you met a hole oh yeah
oh yeah I can taste our words it's
already the greatest film ever made just
run these couple second set I see I was
in a war one oh my god there's lady
tears to judge me as I'm trying to I'm
trying it down we're done she's gonna
back way through Becca I had tears they
didn't give me a star oh my god I think
I think it got me the grave itself the
greatest movie ever no no it's a
greatest Star Wars movie ever which is
even better than the greatest movie ever
congratulations Jake again friends Nick
did it you did it just for these couple
of second to toes at a time we've
watched it on Star Wars
so did you like it it was okay